السؤال حقًا هو ما إذا كان بايدن
سيأخذ لقاحًا إذا تم تقديمه
قبل يوم الانتخابات ، ما الذي قاله
جيدًا قال باميلا جو بايدن إنه
سيأخذ لقاحًا إذا تم تقديمه
قبل يوم الانتخابات ، لكنه أضاف أنه
يريد الاستماع
إلى العالم لأنه  كان يغادر
حدثًا في لانكستر بنسلفانيا ، أخبر
المراسلين أنه يريد أن يرى
شفافية كاملة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بتطوير
وإطلاق لقاح وحذر من
أن تصريحات الرئيس ترامب الخاطئة
حول فيروس كورونا يمكن أن تقوض
ثقة الجمهور.
يقول
إنه قال الكثير من الأشياء غير الصحيحة ،
فأنا قلق إذا كان لدينا لقاح جيد حقًا ،
فسيتردد الناس
في تناوله
ولذا فهو يقوض ثقة الجمهور ،
ولكن أدعو الله أن نحصل عليه إذا كان
بإمكاني الحصول على لقاح  غدًا سأفعل
ذلك إذا كلفتني الانتخابات ، أفعل ذلك
الآن ، يأتي هذا بعد أن قالت كامالا هاريس
إنها لن تثق
في
كلمة الرئيس وحدها بشأن لقاح لفيروس كورونا
يود أن يسمع عن
الفعالية
المتعلقة به من العلماء بايدن
موضحين اليوم أنه
إذا كان هناك لقاح فلن
يكون هناك تأثير سياسي عليه سواء كان
سيأخذ
لقاحًا إذا كان هناك لقاح فعال
وافق عليه العلماء